I just felt in some small way if we
could just bring them back just once
more just to lay them on the ground of
this country once more is something
really worth in this unique and poignant
spectacle is the culmination of five
years work by the artist Rob herd who
spent 15,000 hours and making seventy
two thousand three hundred and
ninety-six shrouded figures it was just
about physical izing that number and
creating a figure for every one of those
names and it was so important that it
was actually each figure is associated
with a name as I would correct as I make
a figure it would be crossed off cost of
a great volumes of books I've got and
that was so vitally important that these
that these weren't just a collection of
of images they are actually representing
an individual my great-great uncle
singing little certain was killed at the
Battle of the Somme and on the day
Sidney was killed he was a Lance
Corporal so it was his job to lead his
men over the top of the trenches and as
he stepped over the top unfortunately he
was shot in the head by German sniper
and instantly killed and you've actually
got a lot of it yes
his brother wrote he had one shot to
write this letter in the heat of a
battle and thinking about what he was
going to say to his mother and knowing
that this news was gonna break her heart
I want you to come down and my
great-great-great uncle's home run off a
fire because they were obviously they
obviously died in the war and they their
bodies were never found
I just want to remember them and keep
their the knowledge of them going this
incredible installation is just the
latest piece of art to commemorate the
Great War from the poetry of Wilfred
Owen to the poppies at the Tower of
London art has long been at the heart of
how we make sense
war and remember the dead as the final
figure is laid here at the Olympic Park
this is yet another poignant reminder
for the terrible scale of the sacrifice
made a century ago Lucy Casa Sky News
[Music]